[Musique]
c'est le plus merveilleux Noël est un
moment magique plein d'émerveillement Je profite d'un
moment pour créer des souvenirs durables avec
ma famille et mes amis derrière ce qui
rend Noël si spécial
sur des gars comme un
camion à l'aire de restauration, je fais juste un bip, je
me sens comme une chute possédée géante
de novembre au Nouvel An ouais je passe des
mois à choisir le cadeau parfait
pour tout le monde, vous savez la seule chose que je
reçois en
retour  ce n'est pas correct mauvais
frottement du dos
rappelez-vous quand les vacances étaient vraiment
amusantes exemple une maman de retour de Noël maman
où est ta vérité cachant ma taille sur
les achats d'arbres de Noël Je
voulais vraiment profiter de Noël cette année
Amy qui est une maman que les mamans ne font pas et la joie
qu'elles donnent  joie qui aide une maman à travailler
la maison est vraiment sympa
oh merci ton père est génial
merci une vaisselle pourquoi joueriez-vous à ça
j'espère que toi et papa dans la chambre tu
peux  nettoyez ceux qui étaient si heureux de
dormir et puis vous frappez la marche et
criez oui pour papa et je
jouais juste un petit jeu amusant, vous
jouez au jeu sept fois six maintenant
[Musique]